[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera parada y les
doy la bienvenida aquí américa este es
el magazine de france 24 dedicado a las
historias de nuestro continente hoy
tenemos una emisión especial dedicada a
la crisis política que atraviesa perú
'déjà vu' y es que el presidente pedro
castillo logró completar un año en el
poder pero la incógnita de si lograra
terminar su mandato de cinco años por lo
pronto pasará a la historia como el
primer jefe de estado en ejercicio del
perú en ser investigado por la fiscalía
no sólo con una pesquisa en su contra
sino con cinco unos primeros
365 días en los que quedó en evidencia
su incapacidad de gobernar y de formar
un gabinete
profundizando la inestabilidad en una
nación que ya ha visto pasar por la casa
de pizarro a cinco mandatarios desde
empecemos el 28 de julio perú conmemora
su independencia y como es tradición en
el marco de la celebración el presidente
debe entregar un balance de su gestión
ante el congreso en esta fecha de 2021
pedro castillo se convirtió en el quinto
presidente del país en cinco años y
ahora en 2022 acudió a esta cita con los
legisladores y con los peruanos con una
antesala de protestas abruptos cambios
en el ministerio del interior- y la
apertura de investigaciones en su contra
por parte de la fiscalía que a su vez
reflejan lo que ha sido su gobierno el
otro era profesor rural y líder sindical
evitó hacer una autocrítica y se
concentró en destacar sus logros sin
embargo su incapacidad para formar un
gabinete que ha quedado en evidencia con
las 59 personas que han nombrado y ha
removido o se han retirado de los
distintos ministerios y una constante
pugna de poder con el congreso a través
de la amenaza de la destitución que ha
enfrentado y ha sobrevivido ya dos veces
estas son la verdadera rendición de
cuentas ante los peruanos castilla no ha
logrado planes que marquen diferencia
con sus antecesores
de referirse al problema adjudicó todo a
una persecución de la oposición
escuchemos parte de sus palabras este
primer año he recibido una bofetada en
una mejilla de aquellos que no aceptaron
perder legítimamente en las elecciones
presidenciales con el voto consciente
del pueblo peruano pero en este segundo
año no voy a poner la otra mejilla si no
extenderle la mano para trabajar juntos
en beneficio del pueblo revisamos ahora
las investigaciones contra castillo son
cinco casos uno de ellos suspendido se
le acusó de presunto tráfico de
influencias en ascenso de integrantes de
las fuerzas armadas también por los
crímenes de organización criminal
presunto tráfico de influencias y
colusión por la adjudicación de
contratos en el caso puente de tarata
también plagio y falsedad por el
presunto plagio de su tesis doctoral
delitos contra la administración pública
en la compra de biodiésel este es el
caso petro perú y el presunto delito de
encubrimiento por los múltiples cambios
en el ministerio del interior
durante su discurso ante el congreso el
jueves castillo negó su responsabilidad
porque a los medios empeñados en
desestabilizar el gobierno no les
interesa difundir los logros sólo se
emiten mentiras y noticias falsas de
pedro castillo solo se emiten esas cosas
acusado de corrupción sin ninguna prueba
se van a cansar de buscar las pruebas
porque no la van a encontrar y hay
algunos legisladores que están pidiendo
un tercer proceso de vacancia
presidencial por las nuevas acusaciones
la constitución peruana otorga inmunidad
a los presidentes y no pueden ser
procesados por la justicia durante su
mandato de cinco años pero si pueden ser
investigados vamos a lima para hablar
con benji espinoza él es el abogado del
presidente del perú pedro castillo
ahogado muchas gracias por acompañarnos
en france 24
nos daría un placer muchas gracias le
pregunto tras los testimonios del ex
secretario presidencial bruno pacheco y
el ex ministro del interior mariano
gonzález entre otras personas que
señalan al presidente castillo la
comisión de fiscalización ya recomendó
acusarlo constitucionalmente cuál es la
defensa para las acusaciones de presunto
encubrimiento tráfico de influencia
organización criminal que pesan en
contra del presidente
esa recomendación de la comisión de
fiscalización del congreso
viola y lesiona frontalmente la
constitución que en el artículo 117 de
nuestra carta política dice que el
presidente únicamente puede ser acusado
constitucionalmente por un solo delito
traición a la patria no tráfico
influencia supuesta organización
criminal ni ningún otro supuesto así que
es una invitación que hace la comisión
de fiscalización para que los
congresistas que voten violen la
constitución el presidente no puede ser
sometido a una acusación constitucional
por ningún otro caso que no sea traición
a la patria durante ese mandato
ahogado y que va a ser entonces usted si
la fiscal general del perú decide
presentar al congreso esta acusación
constitucional en contra del castillo y
pedir a la justicia prisión preventiva
en contra del mandatario
es importante natalia precisar que hace
un tiempo a raíz de una tutela de
derechos que es una acción judicial que
presentamos en representación del
presidente de la republica un juez
supremo de investigación preparatoria ha
establecido que al presidente de la
republica únicamente se le puede someter
una investigación preliminar pero no a
una investigación formalizada según la
ley peruana únicamente cabe la prisión
preventiva en casos de investigaciones
formalizadas no así en investigaciones
preliminares así que eso es
jurídicamente imposible porque ya hay
una decisión del poder judicial en ese
sentido
bueno y si bien usted lo dice la
constitución peruana prohíbe entonces a
la justicia juzgar a un presidente en
ejercicio del cargo pero también el
estado perú tiene acuerdos
internacionales de lucha contra la
corrupción que facultan a un eventual
proceso judicial que va a ser usted
entonces para sacar al presidente
castillo de este lío
lo que establecen los tratados
internacionales como por ejemplo la
convención de las naciones unidas contra
la corrupción en el artículo 30
establece que los estados deberán tener
un equilibrio entre las inmunidades y
por otro lado la persecución penal y en
el perú existe ese equilibrio y que el
marco constitucional lo que establezca
no es una impunidad del jefe de estado
lo que establece que cualquier
investigación se haga a partir de que el
presidente deje el cargo no durante su
mandato no no es impunidad eso es
postergar la investigación y suspender
los plazos de prescripción para que no
se beneficie el procesado
entonces usted está diciendo que el
presidente pedro castillo debe terminar
sus mandatos y una vez lo termine
enfrentará la justicia
en efecto es lo que establece nuestro
modelo constitucional y esa es la
voluntad clara e irrefutable de los
constituyentes peruanos al escribir
nuestra constitución eso es lo que han
establecido porque el sistema peruano
tiene un gobierno presidencialista y por
eso es que el presidente está protegido
por la carta política
ahogado vendí espinoza abogado del
presidente pedro castillo muchas gracias
por su tiempo para france24
vamos a hablar ahora con mariano
gonzález él es el ex ministro del
interior de perú que fue despedido por
el presidente pedro castillo luego de
apenas dos semanas en el cargo tras lo
cual denunció que el mandatario tenía
vínculos con la corrupción ex ministro
gonzález muchas gracias por acompañarnos
en france 24 cuales son puntualmente sus
denuncias en contra del presidente
castillo y cuáles son las pruebas que
tiene desde el momento en que yo acepté
el cargo lo hice única y exclusivamente
por tratar de recuperar el sector
interior cuyo componente principal es la
policía que venía siendo maltratada por
el premier es decir por el ministro
coordinador no a nivel torres y también
indirectamente por todo el gobierno
entonces acepté el reto
porque además veía que la gestión
pública estaba haciendo muy mal maneja
en el gobierno y consideré que era
posible demostrar que desde la izquierda
también se puede hacer una buena gestión
pública una buena gestión administrativa
pero también se puede hacer política
respetando a los contrincantes políticos
respetando al congreso que hace la
función de control político a la
contraloría a los órganos
jurisdiccionales como la fiscalía y el
poder judicial y sobre todo respetando
las libertades y respetando los medios
de comunicación y la libertad de
expresión de manera muy concreta así
empecé pero también era consciente
que podía encontrar
y como que es lo que encontré el otro
camino que era de verificar una
actitud de favorecimiento o de
proclividad
al encubrimiento a la obstrucción a la
justicia y por ende proclividad a apañar
actos de corrupción
y eso es lo que encontré entonces porque
desde el primer momento yo realice
algunos cambios esenciales en la
inteligencia policial también personas
claves es decir personas que estaban en
puestos que no le correspondían por la
especialidad y porque no tenían la más
mínima idea de lo que es el trabajo
inteligencia y que lo único que tenían
era una relación amical directa con el
presidente entonces empecé a cambiar y
ante el primer reclamo le expliqué al
presidente que es indispensable contar
con un aparato de inteligencia lo
suficientemente
capacitado lo suficientemente preparado
tanto para tener inteligencia
estratégica como para también tener
inteligencia operativa y realizar todos
los trabajos propios del sector
ex ministro de usted en apoyo a la
fiscalía organizó un grupo especial para
capturar a los prófugos y a los sobrinos
del presidente castillo creado usted que
con la entrega a la justicia del ex
secretario presidencial bruno pacheco y
la anunciada entrega también del ex
ministro de transporte juan silva el
presidente está contra las cuerdas va a
terminar el mandato
yo no tengo ninguna duda que el jaque
mate
es prácticamente definitivo si hay una
resistencia de parte de él y del entorno
muy cercano sin embargo creo que sólo
son digamos este manotazo de abajo el
mismo el mismo arzobispo de lima el día
de ayer en el te deum en la misa que se
realiza por las fiestas patrias acá en
perú le ha pedido directamente
encarecidamente en la utilidad
la renuncia o sea de una manera muy
fraterna muy delicada como es la de un
pastor pero aún así claro y contundente
también como para que entiende el
presidente que lo más conveniente sería
su renuncia y evitarle un trago amargo
al país y a todos los peruanos pero
tengo mis dudas
si bien es evidente la dificultad que ha
tenido pedro castillo para gobernar y
formar un gabinete de cualquier manera
el congreso peruano estaba bastante
desacreditado de nuevo el escenario de
la destitución no debería replantearse
de alguna manera el uso de la cuestión
de confianza como mecanismo de control
político
lamentablemente esta es una obra teatral
siniestra
y un protagonista y hay un antagonista
que es el congreso pero ambos pareciera
que están digamos trabajando en el mismo
sentido a qué me refiero que se
necesitan se requieren de 87 votos para
lograr la vacancia presidencial y no se
ha llegado en ningún momento a tener
esos votos
probablemente porque hay un grupo de
congresistas en una investigación
también en uno de los casos del
presidente por una por una obra
denominada puente tarata que es una obra
obviamente en la localidad de tarata y
un puente que se va a ejecutar
y al parecer algunos congresistas
también tenían intereses en esa
ejecución de esa obra
se denominó a la presencia de estos
congresistas se les dijo los niños
porque porque era el profesor y los
niños entonces y se quedaron con ese
apelativo
hoy hay cinco o seis congresistas
investigados por ese caso sin embargo
las primeras pesquisas que se están
haciendo a partir de la entrega del
señor pacheco y la fiscalidad tiene
ahora una hipótesis
ampliada sobre ella no la presencia de
seis sino 12 y por otro lado ha
trascendido de otro grupo de
inteligencia estaría trabajando sobre la
posibilidad inclusive de que sean
muchísimos más en otras palabras tan
responsable es el presidente y tan
responsable termina haciendo el congreso
porque está infestado también de
congresistas que se han vendido o sea se
han se han entregado a los intereses
oscuros del entorno presidencial y por
lo tanto creo que eso debería debería
esclarecerse y debería resolverse porque
eso le hace mucho daño al país porque el
congreso tendría que ser la voz
indicada para poder ponerle fin a esta
situación pero no lo está haciendo
mariano gonzález él es el exministro del
interior del perú gracias por
acompañarnos en france 24
muchas gracias gracias por acompañarme
en esta emisión especial de aquí américa
en la producción estuvo jennifer guevara
pueden ver esta emisión y las anteriores
en nuestra página web france24 puntocom
por favor envíenme sus comentarios en
redes sociales a la dirección que viene
en su pantalla y para más información de
nuestro continente sigan viendo france24
[Música]